so the topic of today is oatmeal and I
used to love oatmeal I used to have it
every single day as a breakfast and I
was told that it was healthy and so
today I want to share uh three things
that you probably have never heard
before relating to oatmeal and the
reason I'm bringing this up is because
if you're consuming oatmeal for health
reasons you may change your mind after
watching this video now of course I'm
not telling you not to consume oatmeal I
just want to give you some additional
information to think with that is not
necessarily easy to find when you type
oatmeal on the internet and I'm not
going to even cover what you probably
already know the sugary type of oatmeal
in these little packets this instant
oatmeal tons of sugar you know you
already know that's really bad I want to
talk about the oatmeal that's actually
not sweetened but it's interesting even
in the packets of instant oatmeal that
has tons of sugar apparently you could
still have a little claim there that
says that it's heart healthy I mean
you'll see articles out there that'll
say that oatmeal is one of the
healthiest foods that you can possibly
eat it's considered a superfood it will
lower your cholesterol it will help your
diabetes and blood sugars it will make
your heart healthy so the first thing
I'm going to dive into I'm going to put
a bunch of studies down below so you can
verify what I'm saying is true
is some studies done on oatmeal in
relationship to blood sugars and Insulin
as well as cholesterol now when you read
these studies it does definitely say
that there is a significant Improvement
in cholesterol as well as blood sugars
okay both and that's pretty exciting I
mean like wow because if something is
cholesterol friendly or it's blood sugar
friendly then you know sign me up but if
you actually read the studies it will
say there's a significant decrease in
cholesterol and blood glucose compared
to the control
now what is this mean compared to a
control what is that all about well
you're comparing it to something else
right and that comparison is white bread
that's right white bread so if you
compare anything to white bread it's
going to be better in a significant way
so let's say for example you eat some
white bread okay and let's say it spikes
your blood sugars by 10 points
and then when you eat uh the oats it
only spikes your blood sugars by five
points and then we can say in the study
there's a significant difference there's
a a much less like 50 percent less spike
in blood sugars than the controls but
that 50 Improvement is not just you know
adding this to your diet and seeing an
improvement in blood sugars it's
compared to something else and then when
you read on in the study it says the
Improvement in blood sugars only
occurred right after the meal okay it
didn't occur later on probably because
there's a a nice Spike of blood glucose
when you eat white bread so that was one
point the other thing that they
mentioned the studies is that part of
the study was just consuming three grams
of beta glucan not consuming oatmeal but
just that compound and that created a
lowering of cholesterol and so then by
inference and we can just say well
there's beta-glucan in oats and just by
deductive reasoning it then must create
the same effect act but that's a little
confusing because that's an isolated
compound versus eating it as a whole
grain and then there's other studies
that 29 participants enrolled in the
study they all had diabetes and they did
not see any change with blood glucose
levels between the two so when we talk
about the benefit there's only certain
studies they're talking about and so
when they quote it's heart healthy
they're kind of cherry picking certain
parts of studies and not giving you the
full understanding of what it really is
going to do to your cholesterol levels
or blood sugars in fact the best thing I
think you should do is just start
testing your blood sugars when you
consume it and then not consume it and
then you'll know for yourself but also I
could not find any of these studies
involving the instant oatmeal with all
the added sugar okay somehow those
studies are really hard to find
in relationship to them improving your
blood glucose levels or insulin levels
or cholesterol levels the next topic is
gluten free right because we all know
that oats are gluten free well
apparently they do have a a type of
gluten it's called avanin okay and this
protein has been known to increase
cytokines which are in like an
inflammatory response in your body but
here's the Catch-22 it's delayed you may
not feel any symptoms for days later so
it's going to be very hard to make the
connection between the two
but if you have irritable bowel syndrome
or inflammation or celiac
you may find that eating oats can worsen
the situation and you have to realize
that these glutens which is just a
category of a lot of different types of
proteins
it's like one of the primary uh triggers
for autoimmune diseases especially
Hashimoto's which is a thyroid problem
number three weed killer called
glyphosate it's interesting that the FDA
when they did the reports or studies on
different foods they kind of omitted
oats for some reason but we don't have
to worry about that because Monsanto did
their own studies and that was the
creator of glyphosate and they said that
it's completely safe so we don't really
have to worry about that but of course
the World Health Organization did say
that glyphosate is a carcinogen and
there was a lawsuit that was one in
court by someone being exposed to
glyphosate
and winning millions of dollars because
they developed cancer and the type of
cancer apparently increases the risk for
is called
Non-Hodgkin's lymphoma but another
organization called ewg which I'll put a
link down below when they found traces
of glyphosate weed killer and over 95
percent of samples of oat products and
it's not that this oat is genetically
modified
they use glyphosate as a pre-harvest
drying agent because it can kill the
plant really quick and dry it up and
that's what they use not only in oats
but in wheat I mean this kind of goes
beyond the genetically modified foods
like in the corn the soy canola that
type of thing so anyway if you do have
oats of course you know steel cut would
be much better than the the process
instant oats and if you're going to eat
it make sure it's organic okay unless
you want some weed killer in there but
you may also want to try something
you might want to just skip your
breakfast all together and do
intermittent fasting you'll probably be
shocked to find out how good you
actually feel by not doing a breakfast
in general but that being said if you
want to do a breakfast I think eggs
would be a much better choice now since
we're on the topic of breakfast if you
have not seen my video on how to
transition out of
doing a breakfast in the benefits I put
that video up right here check it out